in this video I'm going to talk about
the modified Allen test so let's get
started the modified Allen test is
performed before collecting an arterial
blood gas on the radial artery now what
is an arterial blood gas this is also
sometimes referred to as an ABG and it's
a blood test that's collected from an
artery that assesses the oxygenation and
acid base balance of a patient and the
blood sample for this test can be
obtained through an arterial line also
known as an art line and think of this
as like direct access to a patient's
radial artery a lot of patients who are
in the ICU have an arterial line or it
can be obtained through a needle stick
via an artery the most common artery
used for this type of test typically is
the radial artery but the femal and the
brachial artery can be used as well now
why do we do a modified Allen test
before we collect an arterial blood gas
sample from the radial artery let's talk
about the radial artery for a moment so
find your thumb located just below your
thumb over where your radial bone would
be is your radial artery and you can
feel it pulsating and then just next
door on the other side where your Ana
bone is located that's your owner artery
now these two arteries work together to
deliver fresh oxygenated blood to your
hand and its structures and we always
want to make sure that these arteries
can do that so this modified Allen test
is going to check blood flow to the hand
to ensure there is good collateral blood
flow flow to the hand in case that
radial artery develops problems after
the ABG collection so in other words it
wants to make sure that your owner
artery can work as backup in case we
need it so now let me demonstrate how to
perform the modified Allen test before
you perform the modified Allen test you
want to turn the patient's hand so the
Palm is facing up have the patient make
a clinch Fist and then find the radial
and oler artery and to help you remember
the steps of this test remember the word
Allen first you're going to apply firm
pressure to the radial and oler artery
at the same time with your thumbs or
fingertips this will temporarily stop
blood flow to the hand then let the
patient open and close their hand
several times the hand will start to
lose its color hence it's going to
appear lighter or blanched loosen
pressure on the ner artery only but keep
pressure on the radial artery then
evaluate the return of blood flow from
the owner artery to the hand a normal
response will be that the hand returns
to normal color hence appears flush
within less than 5 seconds and if this
is the case you know that this radial
artery is good to go for collecting an
arterial blood gas okay so that wraps up
this video if you like to watch more
videos in this series you can access the
link in the description below